un carrusel de las artes
[Música]
maría carolina piña
bienvenidos una vez más a este programa
donde la cultura es noticia les enviamos
un cordial saludo desde parís y abrimos
ya mismo este carrusel que nos pasear a
hoy por el mundo del cine la historieta
y el tango
pasamos tres minutos en compañía del
director de cine franco argentino gaspar
noé quien regresa a las pantallas con su
más reciente largometraje vortex una
radiografía implacable del amor la vejez
y el fin de la vida
en los estrenos del cine francés una
ficción política con mucho de realidad
dantesca y un retrato fresco y musical
de la juventud francesa
fuimos al encuentro del caricaturista
alberto montt y su trabajo cargado de
cinismo y humor lo conocimos en el
último festival internacional de la
historieta de angulema el rockero y
tanguero argentino daniel melingo vino a
nuestra emisora para hablarnos de sil
bucle disco recopilatorio de sus 20 años
de carrera como solista
[Música]
abrimos nuestro programa de hoy con un
nuevo segmento 3 minutos con les
presenta a un artista o una obra de arte
y hoy les hablamos del que llaman el
niño terrible del cine francés gaspar
noé que ignacio en argentina todas sus
películas sus monstruos como en las
llamas han causado revuelo y ahora se
apresta sacudir de nuevo las conciencias
con su último trabajo carrusel de las
artes les habla de este creador original
y provocador que ha marcado la historia
del cine francés
[Música]
no
tres minutos con la
cual decía que te causa tanto gaspar noé
es el autor de seis películas no aptas
para almas sensibles donde se mezclan
violencia sexo y drogas sin embargo
cuando le preguntamos cómo califica el
mismo su cine body como
lúdico porque para este cineasta franco
argentino nacido en buenos aires hacer
cine es un juego en torno a la estética
el lenguaje y las posibilidades del
séptimo arte sus seis largometrajes han
sido estrenados en el festival de cine
de cannes desde sol con tutús en 1998
hasta su más reciente trabajo por texto
es un
festival que importa en qué secciones
estará la película hay varias secciones
[Música]
y ese festival más importante del mundo
así que es como una clínica de partos
hay muchos cuartos bueno poco importante
cuarto uno pareció su bebé pero no me
ser un mosquito
cada película de gaspar noé ha tenido su
lote de escándalo como irreversible y su
violencia extrema o su radical clímax
una cinta de horror y baile aderezado
con drogas
en su último trabajo vortex no es rompe
con sus temáticas predilectas para
narrar el ocaso de la vida a través de
una pareja de ancianos que se
resquebraja tras un diagnóstico de
alzheimer
lo que quería es una chica con
personajes mayores pero cuando uno llega
a los 50 años en general sus padres
están siendo a los 80 y ahí sí se ve que
se derrumban la familia se derrumban con
el paso del tiempo con una degradación
natural de la materia que acaso el
pensamiento y se crean situaciones muy
muy difíciles en cuestión diferente que
contienen también una muerte natural
cuando hay muerte también hay un sentido
desde el tiempo que pasó en la
inutilidad de una existencia
gaspar noé es un adepto de las proezas
técnicas y en vortex cuenta la historia
en split screen pantalla dividida cada
pantalla se ocupa de la vida de uno de
los dos y es como 12 son como vidas que
se cruzan que se invierten pero
sediciosos son dos soledades que es
acompañar si este juicio de parto
natural castigo
con vortex gaspar noé presenta su primer
largometraje para todo público pero
quizás el más personal e implacable de
todos
de la misma manera
también
damos ahora una mirada a la cartelera
del cine francés donde encontramos dos
películas que nos acercan a las altas
esferas del poder y a la juventud
francesa nos lo cuenta abel lópez
en momentos en los que francia elige a
su próximo presidente llega a los cines
la cinta lo mon dieu el mundo de ayer
una ficción sobre la vida política
francesa que podría parecerse mucho a la
realidad sin deformaciones felación
cúmulo analfabeto en esta película
francia tiene una mujer presidenta que
quiere retirarse de la vida pública a
tres días de las elecciones su
secretario le informa que el candidato a
sucederla se verá implicado en un
escándalo de gran envergadura lo que
podría catapultar al aspirante de la
extrema derecha el equipo de la
presidenta tiene entonces tres días para
cambiar el curso de la historia
el mundo de ayer del director de stem
aborda en el cine la posibilidad no tan
remota de que francia tenga un
presidente de ultra tema que ya había
abordado en 2015 con su película en
francés
hojas y bamba del sicced ayer pasamos de
las salas del elíseo a un liceo en el
corazón de parís un liceo que se lanza
en un proyecto ambicioso recibir a
chicos venidos de los barrios populares
y mejorar su rendimiento escolar gracias
al hip hop
esa es la realidad que refleja el
documental alonso pnv on una cinta sobre
la búsqueda del sentido de la vida del
sufrimiento en la adolescencia pero
también sobre el esperanzador camino
hacia el éxito a través de la expresión
artística y de la música
a banda
los invitamos ahora a conocer el trabajo
de un autor de historietas se llama
alberto momia y ha publicado varios
libros de tiras cómicas que han sido
traducidos al francés aunque publicar
libros no ha sido su objetivo para este
autor que está muy activo en internet no
se amplía melissa barra
[Música]
aquí
la ansiedad los miedos o simplemente lo
que pasa en el día a día pero contado
con dibujos monstruos y mucho humor así
es el trabajo de alberto montt sus
recopilaciones de tiras cómicas muy
conocidas en varios países
latinoamericanos han sido publicadas en
francés lo conocimos en el festival
internacional de la historieta de
angulema 2022
las obras están aquí son justo las obras
que he publicado en francia que hasta
ahora son cuatro libros o cuatro y ahora
viene uno nuevo lo que me mueve para
crear es siempre lo que me pasa lo
cotidiano o sea para mí el trabajo de
creación solo tiene que ver con aquello
que me esté pasando y con aquello de lo
que yo quiero hablar es una especie de
ahorro del psicólogo nunca fui a un
psicólogo porque si no dibujar se habría
gastado mucha plata en eso
su último trabajo está dedicado a la
ansiedad un monstruo rojo y es tuto que
nos arruina la vida pero donde más se
puede apreciar el humor de alberto
montes en un blog dosis diarias en el
que publica una viñeta por día y por el
que pasan hasta cien mil personas
diariamente
luego está ilustrando para medios
tradicionales libros revistas periódicos
y poco a poco al ir publicando cosas en
la red fue mudando me entonces hoy en
día casi todo lo que produzco es en
redes y luego los libros son nada más
que un eco de esta producción en redes o
sea para mí lo importante es realmente
lo que sucede en internet los libros son
sólo una consecuencia
más gente está dispuesta al consumo en
línea e incluso a pagar en línea por lo
que consume entonces desde esa
perspectiva también pues no sé
sobrevivir antes en mi cabeza existía
esta idea de que tenías que hacer libros
y eras ilustrador para poder servir con
ilustración y hoy en día cada vez me doy
más cuenta de que no que el libro en
realidad no importa tanto
alberto monti nació en quito y se radicó
en chile pero considera que podría
trabajar en cualquier rincón del planeta
gracias a la tecnología con el tiempo me
dado cuenta de que hoy en día por lo
menos el tema de las fronteras es
bastante relativo o sea creo que con las
redes sociales y con todas las
plataformas que tienes para comunicar en
línea cada vez es menos importante el
tema de dónde vives y de hecho hoy por
hoy podría ir en donde sea siempre o
cuando tenga acceso a internet
[Música]
pasamos ahora a nuestro segmento musical
con una talla olivares que ya se
encuentra conmigo en el estudio natalia
o hemos sido de encuentro en encuentro y
a ti te tocó conocer a un artista
emblemático del rock y del tango
argentino se llama daniel melingo y es
un artista super original que ha tenido
sus pinceladas surrealistas exactamente
muy original es melingo y melingo se
escribe con m mayúscula m de música y m
de meticuloso porque saca ese nuevo
álbum que es una antología que se llama
silvio se cumple tiene 23 éxitos
escogido por el artista argentino de una
manera científica así el plástico
dividido este trabajo no
cronológicamente sino se pare por ritmos
en el tango tenemos varios ritmos que
trabajamos en las canciones como puede
ser el tango propiamente dicho la
milonga el baile criollo y los ritmos de
canciones como puede ser el pasodoble
el foxtrot y también hay un componente
dentro del tango que es más folclórico
con más la música de tierra adentro que
tiene un componente rítmico ternario
no
son 23 canciones en total 23 éxitos
melingo siempre mantuvo una conexión muy
fuerte con sus raíces argentinas el
tango la milonga el folclor como lo
decía pero también una fuerte conexión
con francia como lo indica ese disco que
se llama silva play y qué mejor que una
canción que ilustre bastante bien esa
conexión con francia que se llama
narigón él nos habló justamente de este
videoclip fue una realización del tsc
aquí en parís hace más de 20 años y es
una manera de hacer memoria sobre mis
mis comienzos que fueron ya casi hace 20
años aquí en la ciudad parís con esta
realización de este de este tango esta
milonga emblemática que me representa
presenta muchísimo
el narigón schmeling o no lo digo yo lo
dice el y la canción aquí también lo
llaman el dandy decadente del tango
argentino también ese disco habla de
memoria la memoria es muy compleja y hay
muchos departamentos de nuestra memoria
los músicos trabajamos con la memoria
auditiva los que bailan con la memoria
muscular
física y siempre hay una memoria de
dónde venimos de nuestra identidad muy
importante
recordarse de dónde venimos de dónde
somos para eso sirve la memoria también
saber de dónde venimos
y para reflejar esa memoria que mejor
que esta canción el blues re bético del
7 vida que es una conexión una
colaboración con otro artista argentino
que se llama andrés calamaro gracias
natal y bueno vamos a terminar este
programa vamos a despedir este programa
con la canción de milingo muchísimas
gracias por su sintonía y hasta la
próxima formas
i
[Música]